this is a labor attack ad that was
published on the party's Twitter Channel
yesterday afternoon it essentially has a
picture of Rishi sunak and then
alongside that picture text saying do
you think adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children should go to prison
Rishi sunak doesn't it then points out
that under the Tories four and a half
thousand adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children under 16 served no
prison time I think the difficulty here
is that what labor are doing is taking a
sort of broad figure and trying to pin
it directly for political reasons on the
current prime minister I mean just on a
on a point of the facts here that four
and a half thousand figure dates back to
2010 so that's the last 13 years of that
that applies to Richie sunac of course
has only been prime minister for the
last six months of course he served in
government and been a member of the
party for a bit longer than that of
course he became an MP after 2010 as
well so he wasn't even sitting in
Parliament at the beginning of that
they've been getting criticism even from
their own side as well John McDonnell
the former Shadow Chancellor someone who
clearly isn't that close to kirstama was
a big fan and very close to Jeremy
corbyn but he tweeted last night saying
this is not the sort of politics a labor
party confident of its own values and
preparing to govern should be engaged in
I say to the people who have taken the
decision to publish this ad please
withdraw it we the labor party are
better than this I think maybe what's
particularly unfortunate is that about a
year ago there was a lot of angry
comments from the labor side after Boris
Johnson accused sakir starmer of failing
to prosecute Jimmy Savile while he was
the director of public prosecutions
essentially the defense there was that
um secure storm it wasn't personally
secure stalma that was involved in that
decision now on a similar sort of topic
around sexual assault labor seemed to be
trying to do something similar pinning a
broader Point specifically on the Prime
Minister now they clearly see the
political upside of this to try and
undermine the conservatives claim and
record on Law and Order and push
themselves as the party of Law and Order
I think the danger though is that given
secchist armor has made such a big play
for restoring Integrity if you like and
uh kind of honor to politics quite
vicious attack ads like that do
undermine that sort of pitch from the
labor leader